Imamo kurs kursničke primude,
imamo pravna pravila,
kursona pravila
koja ima uređenu funkcionisanu državu
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanog države
koja su podlano čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti koju imamo državno
dajem na različitom stepenu vlasti.
Koordinacija ima isti stepen vlasti
i saraje.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje. Kada je reč o ljudima?
Krenut ćemo sa ljudima da vidimo
koji to ljudi rade, šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos
prema državi kao organizaciju.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svo stanovništvo,
taj državni aparat čine samo neki ljudi.
Ti ljudi koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim ljude.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u imenu za račun država.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određene poslove.
Zato
da imate određenu državnu službenu lice,
date mu da rade neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu
radu. Uvod u srpskom jeziku je najprostije
i najbolje objasnjeno.
Uzmeš posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom ulicu
i kažeš da je to tvoja nadležnost.
Postoje dve vrste nadražnosti, u principu
i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno u radu državnih
hordana, ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudija
koji je državno službeno lice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državno službeno lice,
da li oni radi isti?